valérie deschaseaux a repris et
moderniser l'entreprise familiale en
cette scierie est le leader européen de
la traverses de chemin de fer ici 250
mètres cubes de chaînes sont valorisés
par jour mais aujourd'hui le parc de
grumes est quasiment vide
toutes les ventes de priver actuellement
qui nous aidaient jusque-là
approvisionner la série en plus
d'éventer nef sont achetés par des
traders qui vous revendre à des chinois
mais si nous actuellement ont stérilisé
l'heure
rennes leurs récoltes il exploite lui il
préserver leurs forêts l'entreprise
emploie 49 salariés et faute de matière
première
l'activité tourne au ralenti nous
arrivons à couvrir mais en diminuant et
des livraisons
la tournée s'arrête jeudi soir afin de
préserver au moins l'activité à 35
heures pour tous les salariés par le
manque de matière pour de matières nous
sommes 8 mai
nous sommes contraints de diminuer le
temps de travail donc nous pénalisons
mon client pire est derrière aussi des
livraisons retardées 30% du chêne
récoltés dans les forêts françaises est
exportée la fédération française du bois
demande des mesures de protection face à
ce problème le député christophe lejeune
a alerté ses collègues parlementaires
il n'y a pas forcément du
protectionnisme à la clé mais il y a une
empreinte carbone qui est nécessaire il
s'est quand même paradoxal que des
forêts implanté en haute-saône soient
exploitées en chine alors que nous avons
les scieries au coeur de ces forêts et
avec des coûts de transport et un impact
de transport qui est nettement moindre
que les simples exportations en chine
si certains propriétaires ont profité
d'une hausse des cours de 25 % ces deux
dernières années il n'est pas sûr que
les acheteurs d'aujourd'hui soient les
clients de demain
la gestion d'une forêt de chênes se fait
sur le long terme d'où l'importance
d'organiser la filière
l'idéal c'est le plan de gestion c'est à
dire que les coupes soit organisée dans
le temps et pour pouvoir dire à ceux qui
utilisent la matière on mettra temps de
volume dans tant de temps sur le marché
est organisé cette cette filière entre
l'amont et l'aval de la filière
l'ukraine et la croatie ont récemment
interdit l'exportation de leurs chaînes
avant d'en arriver là la fédération
française du bois demande l'extension du
label eux réservé pour l'instant à l'eau
nf un label qui garantirait déjà la
transformation du chêne à l'intérieur de
l'espace européen
et de nouvelles réglementations pays